And... okay, here we go... Oh my god, another seven, are you serious? Not my lucky day. This guy... There. Something troubling you? Surely there's been a mistake here. What mistakes do your eyes see, please tell us.
等等……好吧，开始了……天哪，又是七点，你是认真的吗？今天真倒霉。这家伙……好了。有什么烦心事吗？这里肯定搞错了。你的眼睛看到了什么错误，请告诉我们。
Well, the burglar appears to be placed on my highest yielding wheat field. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 208 recorded on November 12, 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co host Ben, we talk about our favorite board games. All right, how's it going? It's been a minute since we chatted. Yeah, it's been a little while. It seems like, I was thinking the other day, is Bryce now doing the On Location podcasts and I'm doing the Homebody podcasts? I haven't decided yet. I mean, I feel like this is a multi-co-host podcast now.
嗯，强盗似乎被放在了我产量最高的小麦田上。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 208 期，录制于 2024 年 11 月 12 日。我是 Connor，今天我和联合主持人 Ben 一起聊聊我们最喜欢的桌游。好的，最近怎么样？我们有一阵子没聊天了。是啊，有一小会儿了。我前几天在想，现在是 Bryce 做外景播客，我做居家播客吗？我还没决定。我的意思是，我觉得这现在是一个有多位联合主持人的播客了。
That's what season two is. I don't think we're either of us. Actually, that's a lie. Bryce is, I think, at the moment, what is it, November 12th? Actually, I don't know if he's left yet, but I know that there is a cascade, is that the right word, of conferences and events in the C++ world about to happen. There's CodeDive. There's Meeting C++ world about to happen. There's CodeDive. There's Meeting C++.
这就是第二季的内容。我不认为我们俩是其中之一。其实，那是谎话。我想 Bryce 现在，今天是 11 月 12 号吧？其实我不知道他是否已经出发了，但我知道 C++ 世界里有一连串——这是正确的词吗？——即将发生的会议和活动。有 CodeDive。有 Meeting C++ 即将发生。有 CodeDive。有 Meeting C++。
I think sandwiched inside of that is the Berlin. I think it's Berlin. I could be wrong. Maybe it's Poland. It's in one of the two Meeting C++ or CodeDive locations, which is Berlin and Wroclaw, Poland. And then I think it's still happening. The Core CPP event in Israel is
我想夹在中间的是柏林。我想是柏林。我可能错了。也许是波兰。它在 Meeting C++ 或 CodeDive 的两个地点之一，也就是柏林和波兰的弗罗茨瓦夫。然后我想它还在进行中。以色列的 Core CPP 活动是
happening after that. And I think Bryce is attending all of that. I think, I think. I chatted with him a few days ago and he said he had to do like, you know, three weeks work of worth. Three weeks worth of work? Wow, that's a tongue twister um in like a couple days because he was heading for travel and i think actually he was just in a conference in new york like pi data nyc where there was some nvidia folks anyways there's always something happening there's always it's always busy on the on the conference circuit c++ alone and then you take in you know all the array language conferences that you do and it's all it's all you guys are always traveling i think honestly that's this like in the midst of whether c++ is crumbling as a an empire or not you know it's
在那之后发生。我想 Bryce 会参加所有这些活动。我想，我想。我几天前和他聊过，他说他得做，你知道，三周的工作量。三周的工作量？哇，那真是个绕口令，嗯，在几天之内，因为他要出发去旅行了，而且我想其实他刚在纽约参加了一个会议，比如 Pi Data NYC，那里有一些英伟达的人。总之，总是有事情发生，会议圈总是很忙，光是 C++ 就这样，然后你再算上你参加的所有数组语言会议，你们总是到处奔波。我觉得老实说，这就是在 C++ 作为一个帝国是否正在崩溃的过程中，你知道，它是
hard to tell in the midst when rome was at the peak of its height. Sure. Whether or not that's happening, I think the single best thing about C++ is the cornucopia of not just conferences, but also podcasts, content, say what you will about competing efforts, but Rust is probably the biggest of those. And I think there's only really one active Rust podcast called Rustation Station. And there's a couple other small ones that come and go that like I think the next currently active one is like at 10 or 15 episodes.
在罗马处于鼎盛时期时很难判断。当然。无论是否正在发生，我认为 C++ 最棒的一点就是不仅有大量的会议，还有播客、内容。不管你怎么评价竞争性的努力，Rust 可能是其中最大的一个。而且我认为真正活跃的 Rust 播客只有一个，叫 Rustation Station。还有几个来来去去的其他小播客，我想下一个目前活跃的播客大概在 10 或 15 期左右。
And there's definitely a few Rust conferences, but definitely nowhere near the number of C++ ones. Anyways, and it's nice to, I don't know, as someone who consumes content, it's nice for there to be more content because I would love to listen to more Rust podcasts that are like more language focused. Anyways. So is this your new recording space? Connor's where I normally talk to Connor from, he has changed. Now I see behind him a good number of books, which I'll ask about in a sec, and a bunch of board games, and a bunch of medals and running numbers and a Sansevieria.
而且肯定有一些 Rust 会议，但绝对远不及 C++ 的数量。总之，作为一个内容消费者，有更多的内容是件好事，因为我很乐意听更多更专注于语言的 Rust 播客。总之。那么这是你的新录音空间吗？Connor，我通常和 Connor 聊天的地方，他换了。现在我看到他身后有很多书，我一会儿会问，还有一堆桌游，一堆奖牌和跑步号码牌，还有一盆虎皮兰。
Mother-in-law's tongue or snake plant, for those who aren't familiar. Yeah, this is actually Professor Snake. It's from a friend of mine, Justin. Justin Kwong, shout out. He got married in September. I was actually emceeing his wedding. Congratulations to him and Jenny. He used to live in Toronto and left to Vancouver.
对于不熟悉的人来说，那是虎尾兰或蛇草。是的，这其实是蛇教授。它来自我的一个朋友 Justin。Justin Kwong，向他致敬。他在九月结婚了。我当时还在主持他的婚礼。祝贺他和 Jenny。他以前住在多伦多，后来搬到了温哥华。
And when he left, I acquired all of his plants, one of which is Professor Snake, who has never been on camera before. Maxwell, my fern plant, is too big to fit back here. So what has happened is I moved at the end of October. My fiance and I used to live at one place. Now we live what was her old place and is now our new place. And I'm not going to stretch this over like 10 episodes where I tell you a story each time about my coach and then my fridge. We moved. It was painful.
他离开时，我接收了他所有的植物，其中之一就是蛇教授，它以前从未上过镜头。Maxwell，我的蕨类植物，太大了，放不回这里。所以发生的事情是我在十月底搬家了。我和未婚妻以前住在一个地方。现在我们住在她以前的地方，也就是我们现在的新家。我不会把它拖成 10 集，每次都告诉你关于我的沙发和冰箱的故事。我们搬家了。这很痛苦。
Oh, I have a couch guy down at Ikea, you know. We had one couch at my old place, which was a hand-me-down from my sister when she also used to live in Toronto. And then she went to Calgary. Almost all my furniture is like acquired from people that left the city while I was moving. And they were like, hey, do you want half my stuff? And I was like, sure, why not? But my fiance had a couch at her place. So we don't need two coaches.
哦，我在宜家有个沙发男，你知道。我旧住处有一个沙发，是我姐姐以前住在多伦多时传给我的。然后她去了卡尔加里。我几乎所有的家具都是在我搬家时从离开城市的人那里弄来的。他们会说，嘿，你想要我一半的东西吗？我就说，当然，为什么不呢？但我未婚妻在她那里有一个沙发。所以我们不需要两个沙发。
So we sold our coach for $30 to... It's basically like the fee for someone just to come and get it from us. We don't... Yeah. I'm actually trying to make money from it. Right. Exactly. It's like, take it away.
所以我们以 30 美元的价格卖掉了我们的沙发给……这基本上就是让人来把它拿走的费用。我们不……是的。我其实是在试图从中赚钱。对。没错。就像，把它拿走吧。
The point being is we're now in a smaller space. So all of my stuff is crammed into this little den. It used to be spread out across the apartment that we used to live in and uh that's why you see yes all the board games and stuff i'm not sure yeah so we were chatting because someone once requested we should do a board game episode i know you are also a board game fan i am so yeah i don't know if you want to talk what's behind me and then you can mention your favorites and we can... Sure, sure. So, we know that Connor likes Scrabble and there are some word board games represented behind you there.
重点是我们现在在一个更小的空间里。所以我所有的东西都塞进了这个小书房。它以前分散在我们住过的公寓里，嗯，这就是为什么你看到，是的，所有的桌游之类的。我不确定，是的，所以我们当时在聊天，因为有人曾经要求我们应该做一期桌游节目。我知道你也是桌游迷，我也是，所以，是的，我不知道你是否想谈谈我身后的东西，然后你可以提一下你最喜欢的，我们可以……当然，当然。所以，我们知道 Connor 喜欢拼字游戏，你身后有一些文字类桌游。
So, you've got one called Letter Tycoon. I'm not familiar with that. But you've got Dixit and Scrabble indeed and Word on the Street. Is that what that says? Yeah. Oh, yeah. Word on the Street. I went through a yeah oh yeah word on the street i went through a phase that that was it's a still a very fun game it's a game where uh yeah of the word
所以，你有一个叫 Letter Tycoon 的。我不熟悉那个。但你有 Dixit 和 Scrabble，确实，还有 Word on the Street。那是上面写的吗？是的。哦，是的。Word on the Street。我经历过一个，是的，哦，是的，Word on the Street，我经历过一个阶段，那仍然是一个非常有趣的游戏，它是一个游戏，嗯，是的，关于文字
games well i mean scrabble is here you can't see it yes yeah it is there um this is this is the $20 version of scrabble if anyone knows you used to be able to order custom Scrabble boards that, you know, you could choose the foldability, you know, if it's a tournament Scrabble board, turnstile, et cetera, you can't get them anymore. A lot of the companies folded during the pandemic or they shut down just because they didn't have the bandwidth. It's like one person shops. If anybody knows a place that I can get a, and not for like 500 USD dollars, because
游戏，嗯，我的意思是 Scrabble 在这里，你看不见它，是的，它在那里，嗯，这是 20 美元版的 Scrabble，如果有人知道的话，你以前可以订购定制的 Scrabble 板，你知道，你可以选择折叠性，你知道，如果是锦标赛 Scrabble 板，旋转台等等，你现在买不到了。很多公司在疫情期间倒闭了，或者因为没有带宽而关门了。这就像一人店。如果有人知道我可以在哪里买到一个，而且不是 500 美元，因为
that is crazy. That's the only ones that I can find I'd be interested Scrabble is definitely my favorite word game word on the street is a game where you take not the full 26 letters but I think it's like 22 of them and you place them on a table in a line on a board and then you'll get given a category like animal. And then you've got 30 seconds to think of the name of an animal and then spell it out. And every time you say a letter, you move that letter one lane towards you. And once you get it three lanes in your direction, you collect that letter and it's the first person to get eight letters. Obviously, though, you go back and forth with the either opponent or the turn so like if you say
那太疯狂了。那是我能找到的唯一的，我会感兴趣的。Scrabble 绝对是我最喜欢的文字游戏。Word on the Street 是一个游戏，你不是拿全部 26 个字母，我想是 22 个，你把它们放在桌子上一排，放在板子上，然后你会得到一个类别，比如动物。然后你有 30 秒的时间想出一个动物的名字，然后拼出来。每次你说出一个字母，你就把那个字母向你的方向移动一个车道。一旦你把它移动了三个车道到你的方向，你就收集那个字母，第一个收集到八个字母的人获胜。当然，你会和对手或轮次来回往复，所以如果你说
alligator that would be a pretty good one because it's a l l i g a t o r so you get two doubles a's and l's so the longer the word it also it gets really fun because towards the end of the game once certain letters are collected all the a's r's l's s's t's you can't use them once your opponent gets them is is that okay? Or you can use them. But there's no benefit, I see. So it's a tug of war. Exactly.
鳄鱼（alligator），那会是一个相当不错的词，因为它是 a l l i g a t o r，所以你有两个双 A 和 L。所以词越长，它也变得越有趣，因为在游戏快结束时，一旦某些字母被收集了，所有的 A、R、L、S、T，一旦你的对手拿到了它们，你就不能用了，这样可以吗？或者你可以用它们。但没有好处，我明白了。所以这是一场拔河比赛。没错。
A 22-way tug of war with all these letters. Yeah. So do you go for, what's a good strategy in that game? I mean, one is trying to get double, trying to get long words in general. Do you try and snipe some of the lesser huge letters perhaps that's a strategy the best strategy is to or and i mean i'm sure everyone has different strategies although it's not a huge it's not like a deep strategy game uh in general the longest word as possible that you can correctly spell because if you misspell it you have to put back all the
一场 22 人的拔河比赛，用这些字母。是的。那么你追求什么，那个游戏里有什么好的策略吗？我的意思是，一个是试图得到双倍，试图得到长词。你是否尝试狙击一些较小的巨大字母，也许那是一个策略，最好的策略是，或者，我的意思是，我相信每个人都有不同的策略，虽然它不是一个巨大的，它不像一个深度的策略游戏，嗯，总的来说，尽可能长的词，你能正确拼写出来的，因为如果你拼错了，你必须放回所有的
letters right okay and then you want there to be a breadth of letters but also if you can get like a double or a triple like sometimes saying the word i don't know daddy or something like that or mommy uh those are bad examples because i don't actually think that would be the answer to any clue but um if you can come up with a word that has a triple you can automatically lock that letter up and especially if you see because it's only three stops until you yeah capture the letter yeah and then usually you want to try and target letters that are either at the edge of your highway like side of the board that you're one away from collecting and you want to defensively try and take back if if your opponent
字母，对吧，然后你希望那里有广泛的字母，但如果你能得到像双倍或三倍，有时说出像，我不知道，爸爸（daddy）或者类似的东西，嗯，那些是坏例子，因为我其实不认为那会是任何线索的答案，但嗯，如果你能想出一个有三倍的词，你可以自动锁定那个字母，特别是如果你看到，因为只有三个站位直到你，是的，捕获那个字母，是的，然后通常你想尝试瞄准那些要么在你的高速公路边缘，也就是板子的一侧，你离收集还差一个，你想防御性地尝试夺回，如果你的对手
has like a t and an r coming up something with like a website like twitter then you can get it you know back into the middle very fun game not many people know about it sounds fun yeah there are a few of those kind of tug of war the tug of war style it reminds me of is um a game called that i haven't played but it's called watergate and it's for two players and it's so it's the strange it's supposed to be a really good two-player game strangest idea or it's that kind of theme for a game it's about the watergate scandal and one one side is playing you know nixon's administration and the other side is playing basically the press one side trying to you know get to informants first before they get sort of taken out of the game and you're playing tug of war with a you
有像 T 和 R 即将出现，像 Twitter 这样的网站，那么你可以把它，你知道，带回中间，非常有趣的游戏，没多少人知道它。听起来很有趣，是的，有几种那种拔河，拔河风格，它让我想起了一个我没玩过但叫 Watergate 的游戏，它是给两个玩家玩的，它是，所以它是奇怪的，它应该是一个非常好的双人游戏，最奇怪的想法，或者它是那种游戏的主题，它是关于水门事件的，一方扮演，你知道，尼克松政府，另一方基本上扮演媒体，一方试图，你知道，在告密者被从游戏中拿走之前先找到他们，你在玩拔河，如果你把它
know if you get it all the way to your side then then nixon gets impeached and removed and if nixon gets it all the way to his side it's he he wins it's that it's a kind of tug of war game interesting i've never heard of that and i'd be interested in playing because i did recently watch what's the watergate movie called it's not called watergate it's all the president's men all the president's men yes robert redford yeah robert redford and dustin hoffman i believe and there was obviously a couple other people in it where my fiancee and i are watching we're trying to get our way slowly through the afi america's institute 100 and it's always it's a it's a toss-up sometimes the movies really really age well and sometimes they're painful to watch yeah but this one i thought was really really good um and also
一直拉到你这边，那么尼克松就会被弹劾并被免职，如果尼克松把它一直拉到他那边，他，他赢了，这是一种拔河游戏，有趣，我从来没听说过，我会感兴趣去玩，因为我最近看了，水门事件的电影叫什么来着，它不叫水门事件，是《总统班底》（All the President's Men），《总统班底》，是的，罗伯特·雷德福，是的，罗伯特·雷德福和达斯汀·霍夫曼，我相信，而且显然里面还有几个人，我和我未婚妻正在看，我们正试图慢慢看完 AFI 美国电影学会的 100 部，有时这很难说，电影有时真的非常经得起时间考验，有时看得很痛苦，是的，但这一部我觉得真的非常好，嗯，而且还有
what's sad and that's you know everyone loves their partners but um she my partner is so much better at understanding like the context of a movie the movie not to ruin anything uh but it stops before all the stuff that was in the headlines at the time right place it's just a lead up yeah it goes through that like in rapid fire at the end and i was like what that's the most exciting part but because i didn't live through it like i'm not really familiar with what happened but at the time everybody would have known like they were telling the story that people hadn't heard, not the story that was in the news. She immediately picked up on that. And I was like, what?
令人难过的是，那是，你知道，每个人都爱他们的伴侣，但嗯，她，我的伴侣在理解电影的背景方面要好得多，电影，不剧透任何东西，但它在当时头条新闻里的所有事情发生之前就停止了，对吧，它只是一个铺垫，是的，它在最后像连珠炮一样经过，我就像，什么，那是这部分最令人兴奋的，但因为我没有经历过，所以我不太熟悉发生了什么，但在当时每个人都会知道，就像他们讲述的是人们没听过的故事，而不是新闻里的故事。她立刻就明白了。我就像，什么？
How could they do that? And she's like, well, you have to understand, like, we're watching this, you know, decades later. 40 years after the fact. Yeah. I was like, well, now they got to make a follow up so that the young kids that didn't live through it, because it's pretty insane what happened there. Anyways, back to board games. Watergate. I'll put it on my list. it's supposed to be really good um i haven't played it but uh i i do watch a youtube
他们怎么能那样做？她说，嗯，你必须明白，就像，我们是在几十年后看这个的。事后 40 年。是的。我就像，好吧，现在他们得拍个续集，让那些没经历过的小孩子看，因为那里发生的事情太疯狂了。总之，回到桌游。Watergate。我会把它列入我的清单。它应该非常好，嗯，我没玩过，但嗯，我确实看一个 YouTube
channel called actual lol actual lol like lol like actual ol actual lol okay yeah hard to say but um yeah it's a british guy he reviews board games. And Watergate's one of the ones he recommends. Yeah, so I see several others there. Mastermind. Mastermind, of course, is a programmer type game, right? Mastermind is the game that I borrowed the exact matches problem from in Amar Shah's talk, Point Free or Die. And then I talked about it. I think it was in the composition intuition talk that i gave at cpp north a year ago i vaguely remember something yeah and it's actually hard to
频道叫 Actual Lol，Actual Lol，像 LOL 一样，Actual Ol，Actual Lol，好的，是的，很难说，但嗯，是的，他是一个英国人，他评论桌游。而 Watergate 是他推荐的游戏之一。是的，所以我看到那里还有几个其他的。Mastermind。Mastermind，当然，是一个程序员类型的游戏，对吧？Mastermind 是我从 Amar Shah 的演讲《Point Free or Die》中借用精确匹配问题的游戏。然后我谈到了它。我想是在我一年前在 Cpp North 给出的《Composition Intuition》演讲中，我模糊地记得一些，是的，而且它其实很难
find that game that version of mastermind is a multi-person mastermind that has like a spinning ball where like up to four people can play and guess i only never played that version, but it's hard to actually find the old school, just rectangular with rounded edges, gray version of the game. Right. Let's see. I see Hive, Wingspan, Patchwork 2, Codenames. Codenames is a good game, but really difficult, I found. You have to have the right, you have to have people that are on the right wavelength. It can be.
找到那个版本的 Mastermind 是一个多人 Mastermind，有一个像旋转球的东西，最多四个人可以玩和猜，我从来没玩过那个版本，但很难真正找到老派的，只是矩形带圆角的，灰色版本的游戏。对。让我们看看。我看到 Hive，Wingspan，Patchwork 2，Codenames。Codenames 是个好游戏，但我发现真的很难。你必须有正确的，你必须有在正确波长上的人。可能是。
Yeah, I think so it can be a lot of fun but there can be some frustration like where someone goes for or should we explain the game should you explain the game for those that might not have heard of codenames yeah so in code it's a two-player game at least i've played two players um you're sitting across the table from each other and between you is a matrix of what five by five matrix of yep cards with words on them uh with words on them and you each have a key to this matrix which denotes some of the cards as secret agents or bombs or basically you you they are to be avoided yeah like so you get a five by five grid where you have two codes sayers and then two people that are trying to guess and the people that are saying the clues have a little five by five card that denotes i think it's going to be like seven red ones eight blue ones and then one black one
是的，我想是的，它可以很有趣，但可能会有一些挫折感，比如有人去，或者我们应该解释这个游戏吗？你应该为那些可能没听说过 Codenames 的人解释一下这个游戏吗？是的，在 Codenames 里，这是一个双人游戏，至少我玩过双人，嗯，你们坐在桌子对面，中间是一个矩阵，什么，5x5 的矩阵，上面有词的卡片，嗯，上面有词，你们每个人都有这个矩阵的钥匙，它标明了一些卡片是秘密特工或炸弹，或者基本上你，你，它们是要避免的，是的，所以你得到一个 5x5 的网格，你有两个代码说书人，然后两个试图猜的人，说线索的人有一张小的 5x5 卡片，标明了，我想大概是 7 个红色的，8 个蓝色的，然后 1 个黑色的
and your goal is you want your red teammate somehow to guess the red ones the blue for blue but never guess black because that's the equivalent of sinking the ape in a game of billiards. On each turn, you are trying to give, I think, a single word clue. One word, yes. That somehow leads your opponents to guess one or more of the
你的目标是你希望你的红色队友以某种方式猜出红色的，蓝色猜蓝色的，但永远不要猜黑色，因为那相当于在台球游戏中沉掉 8 号球。在每一轮，你都在尝试给出，我想，一个单字线索。一个词，是的。以某种方式引导你的对手猜出一个或多个
hopefully related words in the matrix. Obviously, the ones you want them to guess, the red ones, and not the ones you want them to avoid. Oh, no is my son just sent me a dad joke where the bad rainbows go uh i have no idea prism oh that's a dad joke we'll keep that in we'll keep that in yes so code names is uh and what makes it difficult is you don't have an We'll keep that in. We'll keep that in. Yeah, so Codenames is... And what makes it difficult is you don't have an unlimited number of turns, right?
矩阵中希望相关的词。显然，你想让他们猜的是红色的，而不是你想让他们避免的。哦，不，我儿子刚给我发了一个冷笑话，坏彩虹去哪了，嗯，我不知道，棱镜，哦，那是个冷笑话，我们会保留那个，我们会保留那个，是的，所以 Codenames 是，嗯，是什么让它变得困难，你没有一个，我们会保留那个，我们会保留那个。是的，所以 Codenames 是……是什么让它变得困难，你没有一个无限数量的回合，对吧？
The timer counts down every turn. You only have a limited number of turns to uncover all the... Or identify all the good words. I've never played that way. Yes. Wait, maybe I've been playing wrong for the entirety of my Cenames. Well, there is a mechanic like that. I don't know if it's a pure time limit or if it's just that when the quote unquote wrong words are guessed, they count against you and they decrease the time limit. There is some mechanic like that, the way I've played it.
计时器每一轮都在倒计时。你只有有限的回合数来揭开所有的……或者识别所有的好词。我从来没那样玩过。是的。等等，也许我整个 Codenames 生涯都玩错了。嗯，确实有那样的机制。我不知道它是纯时间限制，还是说当所谓的错误词被猜中时，它们会扣除你的分数，并减少时间限制。确实有那样的机制，我玩的方式是这样的。
I think we might be conflating. I could be wrong because I've actually never played this version but there is the solo code names where you play with just a partner and it's you against like a number of turns and then there's code names versus a team so the the one you're explaining i'm guessing you've got n number of turns and every you know wrong guess decreases something and if uh yes and it's a cooperative game for two players. Like I'm cooperating with the person across the table. Okay. Yeah.
我想我们可能混淆了。我可能错了，因为我其实从来没玩过这个版本，但有单人 Codenames，你只和一个伙伴玩，是你对抗一定数量的回合，然后有 Codenames 对抗一个团队，所以你解释的那个，我猜你有 N 个回合，每一个，你知道，错误的猜测会减少一些东西，如果，是的，这是一个给两个玩家的合作游戏。就像我和桌子对面的人合作。好的。是的。
I've never played this version. And so the version I'm used to playing is you play against a team and you're trying to get your teammate to guess your color, which is either red or blue. And you're trying to definitely avoid the black, but also trying to avoid the blue cards. Because if you accidentally guess your opponent's card, they still get that as one of their guesses. So now they have one less thing to guess.
我从来没玩过这个版本。所以我习惯玩的版本是你对抗一个团队，你试图让你的队友猜出你的颜色，要么是红色要么是蓝色。你绝对试图避免黑色，但也试图避免蓝色卡片。因为如果你不小心猜到了对手的卡片，他们仍然会把那个作为他们猜测之一。所以现在他们少了一个要猜的东西。
And the tricky thing is when you say a clue, you give it a number. Like a classic one is there'll be like some geography or cities like Canada, Paris. But then it'll also have something like pyramid. And so you'll want to say something like geography for two. but you want to make sure that they don't guess pyramid because it could be the opponent's right guess or it could just be a neutral one so you want to say okay if it's what did i say paris and canada you want to say something that is leans more towards like jurisdictional borders, like jurisdictions maybe,
棘手的事情是当你给出一个线索时，你给它一个数字。比如一个经典的例子是会有一些地理或城市，比如加拿大，巴黎。但它也会有像金字塔这样的东西。所以你会想说像地理，两个。但你想确保他们不会猜金字塔，因为它可能是对手的正确猜测，或者它可能只是一个中性的，所以你想说，好的，如果它是，我说了什么，巴黎和加拿大，你想说一些更倾向于像司法边界的东西，比如司法管辖区，也许，
versus geography that could get conflated. Landmarks, yeah. Yeah. That's right. I'd forgotten you say the number of words that you're cluing. Yeah. In each round. And your opponents can guess up to that number. Or they can guess as many as they like.
而不是可能被混淆的地理。地标，是的。是的，没错。我忘了你说你要提示的词的数量了。是的。在每一轮。你的对手可以猜到那个数字。或者他们可以猜他们喜欢的任意数量。
They don't have to guess the number you said. They could sort of leave it in reserve for the next guess and then so they can get some more information by combining successive clues potentially this is where because i whenever i played board games in the past like pre-pandemic especially when i was younger i used to play with actuaries and even people in tech we all take board games very seriously so there's a set of rules where yeah you you can say n uh as the maker of the clue and then like you said you can you can guess zero if you want and just say pass right and then in the future if you ever go perfect if you go one for one or two for two you get a bonus guess right and so you can you can make your way through and there's another way where the if it's close to the end and it's like a last shot Harold
他们不必猜你说的那个数字。他们可以把它留到下一次猜测，所以他们可以通过结合连续的线索潜在地获得更多信息，这就是因为每当我过去玩桌游时，特别是疫情前，尤其是当我年轻的时候，我曾经和精算师甚至科技行业的人一起玩，我们都非常认真地对待桌游，所以有一套规则，是的，你，你可以说 N，作为线索的制造者，然后像你说的，如果你想，你可以猜零，直接说通过，对吧，然后在未来如果你总是完美，如果你一猜一个中，或者二猜两个中，你会得到一个奖励猜测，对吧，所以你可以一路走下去，还有另一种方式，如果接近尾声，就像最后一击，哈罗德，
Mary, you can say, I can't remember what the word is, infinity or like negative one. And then they can have as many guesses as they want. Or you could just say like seven so that like they get as many guesses. Yeah. So they get as many as they left. And it can become very strategic where you'll guess like two out of the three because you're definitely sure. And it's narrowed down to two.
玛丽，你可以说，我不记得那个词是什么了，无穷大或者像负一。然后他们可以有任意多的猜测。或者你可以只说像七，这样他们就得到任意多的猜测。是的。所以他们得到他们剩下的任意多。这会变得非常有策略性，你会猜像三个中的两个，因为你绝对确定。而且它缩小到了两个。
But like you don't want to guess the opponent so you'll save it for a bonus but i've played with people where they don't understand all those rules and they're like what are you doing you're cheating here getting a bonus guess or um and it's like no no that's the rule anyway see sometimes that's a simplify but i've played where someone will say like something for two and it's very obvious what those two are in hindsight. But then like the person was, oh, I actually didn't read all the cards. I only read the first two columns. And then it's like, well, you wouldn't have made that quick if you had read the remaining, you know, 10 cards. Anyways, very fun game, if not leads to some contentious moments with family members and friends.
但就像你不想猜到对手，所以你会把它留作奖励，但我玩过有人不理解所有那些规则，他们就像，你在做什么，你在这里作弊，获得奖励猜测，或者，嗯，就像不不，那是规则，总之，有时那是一个简化，但我玩过有人会说像什么东西，两个，事后看来那两个是什么非常明显。但那个人，哦，我其实没读所有的卡片。我只读了前两列。然后就像，好吧，如果你读了剩下的，你知道，10 张卡片，你就不会做出那个快速决定了。总之，非常有趣的游戏，如果不是导致与家人和朋友之间的一些争议时刻的话。
Yeah. So, yeah, I am an avid board game player. Yeah, what are your favorites? I don't see any behind you, but I'm sure there's in a different room. They are all in the cupboard on my right, which is full of them. I would have to say my favorite game, and this is just one that I was playing. So, when I was working in the uk for electronic arts in chertsey back in the day we would play settlers of katan it's just called katan in america these
是的。所以，是的，我是一个狂热的桌游玩家。是的，你最喜欢什么？我没看到你身后有任何东西，但我肯定在另一个房间里有。它们都在我右边的柜子里，里面装满了它们。我不得不说我最喜欢的游戏，这只是我正在玩的一个。所以，当我在英国为 Electronic Arts 在 Chertsey 工作时，我们过去常玩《卡坦岛定居者》，这些天在美国它只叫《卡坦岛》，但我知道它是《定居者》，因为它在德国被称为《卡坦岛的定居者》，我们每天午餐时间都玩，你知道，我们利用午餐时间来玩。而且大约需要一个小时。因为《定居者》或《卡坦岛》，《卡坦岛》有一个扩展包叫《航海者》。原来的游戏，据我所知，它是被设计为《航海者》。《卡坦岛》，或《卡坦岛定居者》，没有船的部分，是原来的游戏，被削减以使其可销售。这是一个四人游戏，持续大约一个小时，对吧？所以总之，那个游戏在混合策略和运气方面非常棒。我真的，真的，不知道还有多少其他游戏
days but i know it as settlers because it was called dc love on katan in germany we would play it every lunchtime every day you know we would take the lunchtime just to play. And it takes about an hour. Because Settlers or Catan, Catan has an expansion called Seafarers. The original game, I understand, as it was designed, was Seafarers. Catan, or Settlers of Catan, without the boats part, is the original game that's cut down to make it the marketable. This is a four-player game that lasts about an hour, right? So anyway, that game is just great in terms of how it mixes strategy and luck. It's a really, really, I don't know really of many other games
能把运气和策略结合得这么好。而且有多种路径可以走，你知道，取决于你从哪里获得定居点以及它们生产的频率。而且，你知道，你可以追求像最大军队、最长道路这样的东西。你可以追求发展卡。你可以追求定居点。你可以追求道路建设。然后游戏随着你的进行而发生转变，因为你必须从建造
that do such a good job of mixing luck and strategy. And there are multiple paths to take, you know, depending on where you get your settlements and how often they produce. And, you know, you can go for things like largest army, longest road. You can go development cards. You can go settlements. You can go road building. And then the game pivots as you play because you have to start out building
定居点和道路开始，但为了达到 10 个胜利点，你或多或少必须开始在某个时候升级到城市，这需要不同的卡片分配，不同的策略，因为城市需要
settlements and roads but then in order to make it to 10 victory points you more or less have to start upgrading to cities at some point and that takes a different distribution of cards, a different strategy because cities require
我想是石头和小麦，嗯，来建造，而道路是砖块和木头，所以完全不相干的材料，你需要以某种方式获得，对于一个小游戏来说，有这么多东西，我的意思是，它，它对我来说是一种，它是一个完美的大小，嗯，里面有这么多东西，里面有这么多组合，你知道，你只是放下定居点，你放下道路，你有一手牌，你正在花牌，你正在从每次掷骰子产生的东西中获得牌，这是一个伟大的游戏，我过去每天都玩，我总是对它情有独钟，我只玩过卡坦岛，我想
I think it's stone and wheat uh to build whereas whereas roads are brick and wood so completely disjoint materials that you need to somehow get and there's just such a lot for such a smallish game i mean it's it's a sort of a perp for me it's a perfect size um there's so much in it there's so much combinatorially in it you know it's just you're putting down settlements you're putting down roads you've got a card a hand of cards and you're spending cards and you're getting cards from what produces every time the dice are rolled it's a great game i used to play every day i always have a soft spot for it i've only played katan i think
三四次，我每次玩都很喜欢。我其实不确定为什么我从来没迷上它。我想可能是因为我先发现了《卡卡颂》，这两个游戏。我其实会说《卡卡颂》有——《卡卡颂》是一个工人放置游戏。对吗？是的。那是那个有米宝（meeples）的吗？
three or four times i've loved it every time i played it. I'm not actually sure why I never got into it. I think it's probably because I found Carcassonne first and both of those games. I'd say actually Carcassonne has- Carcassonne's a worker placement game. Is that right? Yeah. That's the one with the meeples?
是的，完全正确。它是我第二喜欢的游戏，遥遥领先，因为它是一个需要一分钟或两分钟来解释，两分钟玩就能掌握要点的游戏。但它其实有，它就像一个轻策略游戏，其实有很多深度。而且它在和《卡坦岛》类似的盒子里。所以我认为我先发现了《卡卡颂》，爱上了那个。
Yes, exactly. It's my second favorite game by far because it's a game that takes like one minute or two minutes to explain, two minutes of playing it to get the gist of it. But it's actually got, it's like a light strategy game that actually has a lot of depth to it. And it's in the similar box of Catan. So I think I discovered Carcassonne first, fell in love with that.
如果不是，我会爱上《卡坦岛》。但《卡坦岛》，我偶然发现了这个 Instagram 短片。我会试着找到它，获取音频并剪辑进去。好的，开始了。天哪，又是七点。你是认真的吗？今天真倒霉。这家伙。有什么烦心事吗？
If not, I would have fallen in love with Catan. But Catan, I came across this Instagram reel. And I will try and find it and get the audio and cut it in. Okay, here we go. Oh, my God, another seven. Are you serious? Not my lucky day. This guy. Something troubling you?
这里肯定搞错了。你的眼睛看到了什么错误，请告诉我们。嗯，强盗似乎被放在了我产量最高的小麦田上。这里肯定搞错了。你的眼睛看到了什么错误，请告诉我们？嗯，强盗似乎被放在了我产量最高的小麦田上。恐怕没有搞错。但你的人民不是在享受用我的小麦做的面包吗？你的人民不是住在我给你的资源建造的石头大厅里吗？你完美地说明了我的观点。我们当时在进行贸易。我的人民不再需要你的面包了。
Surely there's been a mistake here. What mistakes do your eyes see, please tell us. Well, the burglar appears to be placed on my highest yielding wheat field. Surely there's been a mistake here. What mistakes do your eyes see, please tell us? Well, the burglar appears to be placed on my highest yielding wheat field. I'm afraid no mistake has been made. But are your people not enjoying bread made from my wheat? And are your people not living in stone halls from the resources that I've given you? You illustrate my point perfectly. We were engaged in trade. My people no longer have use for your bread.
我们从北方拿羊肉。但我们呢？我们现在是朋友，我们是盟友。那件事呢？橙色王国的人民不结盟。我们曾经有过盟约！我们曾经有过盟约。如果你认为那是一个盟约，
We take lamb from the north. But what about us? We're friends now, we're allies. What about that? People of the Orange Kingdom do not make alliance. We had an alliance! We had an alliance. If you thought that was an alliance,
那你真的是个傻瓜。我宁愿作为傻瓜活一千辈子，也不愿作为暴君呼吸一口气。我刚，我刚赢了，什么，是的，它有最长道路，哦，是的，真的，好的，我想看看这会走向哪里，那真是虎头蛇尾，赢了甚至感觉都不好，我想我正在经历恐慌发作。我不想清理这个。它太有趣了。这是这两个家伙，或者其实是一个家伙扮演三个角色，他们在玩《卡坦岛》桌游，他们说，在某个时候他就像，
then you truly are a fool. I'd rather live a thousand lives as a fool and breathe a single breath as a tyrant i just i just won what yeah it's got longest road oh yeah true okay i wanted to see where this was going that's anticlimactic winning that didn't even feel good i think i'm having panic attack. I don't want to clean this up. It was so fun. It's these two guys, or it's actually one guy playing three characters, and they're playing Board Game of Catan, and they're saying, at some point he's like,
我不再和你交易我的小麦了。然后他进入了这些英国口音，就像，我不敢相信我们有协议。他就像，吧啦吧啦吧啦。他们来回说了大概 40 秒，如果这是像，你知道，莎士比亚中世纪什么的。然后第三个家伙，他只是像看着它发生，就像，其实，我不会说出来。我不会说出来，因为我不想毁了它。
I'm no longer going to trade my wheat with you. And then he goes into these UK accents of like, I can't believe we had an agreement. And he was like, blah, blah, blah. And they go back and forth for like 40 seconds if this is like, you know, a Shakespearean medieval whatever. And then the third guy who's just like watching it happen is like, actually, I won't say it. I won't say it because I don't want to ruin it.
但总之，他只是像打断了，然后游戏结束了。而且，你必须至少玩过一次《卡坦岛》才能理解它的滑稽之处。是的。让它变得好的事情之一是，在任何一轮，你都有很多选择要做，你知道，你有计划来提升你自己的地位，你可以尝试搞砸其他玩家，你可以竞相建造道路来切断人们，你可以，但你总是，你有一手牌，对吧，你可能，你可以买一张发展卡，或者建造一条道路，或者交换，你知道，在港口交换卡片，如果你有一个港口，或者你知道，所以有
But anyways, he just like interrupts and then the game's over. And it's, you have to have probably played Catan at least once to understand the hilarity of it. Yeah. One of the things that makes it good is on any turn you have a number of choices of what to do you know you have plans to advance your own standing and you can try and screw up other players you can be racing to build roads to cut people off you can be but you always have you have a hand of cards right and you might you you could buy a development card or build a road or exchange you know exchange cards maybe at a port if you have a port or you know so there's
一个选择，总有一个选择要做，这就是让它，而且它是一种快节奏，就回合不会拖沓而言，它也是一个，嗯，这就是为什么我也喜欢《卡卡颂》，它是一个隐藏的统计学游戏，如果我没记错的话，是的，就像，嗯，在《定居者》里，完全正确，在《定居者》里，统计数据不是隐藏的，它们其实暴露在板子上，所以你铺设岛屿的六边形瓷砖，对吧，岛屿是由六边形瓷砖组成的，每个六边形瓷砖是，嗯，五种景观类型之一，它们生产，嗯，各种资源，所以你有，嗯，牧场生产羊，小麦田生产小麦，山脉生产石头，嗯，我想矿山生产砖块，嗯，另一个是什么，森林生产木头，对吧，然后一个瓷砖是沙漠，只是
a choice there's always a choice over what to do and that's what makes it and it's a kind of a fast paced in terms of like the turns don't drag it's also a game of um which is why i like carcassonne as well it's a hidden game of statistics if i recall correctly yes like well in settlers exactly in settlers the statistics are not hidden they're actually exposed on the board so you lay out the hex tiles for the island right the island is made of hex tiles and every hex tile is uh one of five landscape types which produce um the various resources so you've got um pasture producing sheep wheat fields producing wheat mountains producing stone uh my i think mines producing brick and uh what's the other one forest producing wood right and then one tile is desert just the
瓷砖的方式意味着岛屿有一个瓷砖是沙漠，那就是强盗最初居住的地方，然后在那块瓷砖上，你放置计数器，指示每个计数都有一个数字在上面，对吧，对应于掷两个骰子，对吧，所以想法是当那个数字出现时，带有那个数字的瓷砖将生产它的资源，对吧，但数字上也有点，在小数字瓷砖上的数字，嗯，点的数量指示概率，所以 8 和 6 显然是最高概率，所以如果你掷出一个 7，当然，这是两个骰子最高概率的，那什么都不生产，那就是强盗移动的时候，掷出
way that the tiles are mean that the island has one tile which is desert and that's where the robber lives to begin with and and and then across those tiles you you lay counters which indicate that each count has a number on it right corresponding to a roll of two dice right so the idea is that when when that number comes up the tile with that number will produce its resource right but also there's dots on the on the numbers on the number on the little number tiles um and the number of dots indicates the probability so eight and six obviously are the highest probability so if you roll a seven which of course is the ultimately highest probability with two dice that doesn't produce anything that's when the robber moves and the person who rolled the
7 的人把强盗移动到他们想要的任何瓷砖上，然后从那个瓷砖上有定居点的人那里偷一张卡片，这就是掷出 7 的全部意义，对吧，掷出 7 是最常见的掷法，但它不，如果你掷出一个 7，每个人都必须丢弃他们的手牌，最多七张，对吧，所以有那个元素，你可能正在建立一个卡片库存，但如果你不花得足够快，你就会冒着掷出 7 的风险，然后你必须丢弃，我想你必须丢弃一半，其实可能不是七张，可能是半数，我忘了规则了，这非常老实说，嗯，我不太熟悉这个游戏，但像掷骰子游戏（craps-esque），是的，是的，好吧，然后一直到，所以显然
seven moves the robber to whichever tile they want and then steals a card from someone with a settlement on that tile that's the whole thing about rolling a seven right rolling a seven is the most common role but it doesn't a you if a seven is rolled everyone has to discard their hand cards down to a maximum of seven right so there's that element you could be building up a stockpile of cards but if you don't spend them quickly enough you run the risk that a seven is rolled and then you have to discard i think you have to discard half of them actually it might not be down to seven it might be half i forget the rule this is very honestly uh i'm not super familiar with the game but craps-esque where yes yes well and then all the way down to like so obviously
你铺设岛屿，你铺设瓷砖上的数字，然后你做的第一件事是每个人在瓷砖之间的顶点上放置两个起始定居点，所以每个定居点，对吧，是的，边界有效地有三个瓷砖围绕它，所以有三个机会生产资源，但当然你想把你的定居点放在与高概率瓷砖接壤的顶点上。是的。所以第一个人，第一个去的人得到一个优势，因为他们得到第一选择。而且它是蛇形的，对吧？
you lay out the island you let you lay out the numbers on the tiles and then the first thing you do is everyone places two starting settlements on the on the vertices between tiles so each each settlement right yeah borders effectively has three tiles around it so three chances to produce resources but of course you want to put your settlements on the vertices that border high probability tiles. Yes. So the first person, the first player to go gets an advantage because they get first pick. And it's snakes, right?
如果我没记错，就像选择，或者人们放置东西的方式，它是蛇形的。对吗？是的。是的。而且《卡坦岛》的好处也是它的重玩性，就像你解释的，你每次设置板子的方式，你每次都得到一个全新的，是的，虽然有些游戏像《机器人反弹》（Robot Ricochet），我喜欢那个游戏，你听说过吗？不，我知道我有《机器人拉力赛》（Robo Rally），不，《机器人拉力赛》，我也听说过。但《机器人反弹》是一个非常快的游戏。
If I recall, like the picking of, or like the way that people place things, it's snakes. Is that correct? Yeah. Yeah. And the nice thing about Catan too is is the replayability of it that's like you're explaining of the the way that you set the board up every single time you get a brand new yeah where there is some games like robot ricochet i love that game have you ever heard of it no i know i've got robo rally no robo rallyally I've heard of as well. But Robot Ricochet is a very quick game.
当我在硅谷时，亚马逊有一些人有一个桌游小组，至少每两周见一次，有时一周一次。我们晚上会玩两三场游戏，我们总是以《机器人反弹》结束。那个游戏的重玩性不是很好，如果你真的研究板子的话，因为它有四个象限，每个象限都可以翻转。所以你得到一定数量的新东西，但每个象限总是会是一样的，
When I was down in Silicon Valley, there was some guys at Amazon that had a board game group that would meet at least once every two weeks, sometimes once a week. And we would play two or three games in the evening, and we would always finish with Robot Ricochet. And the replayability of that game isn't great if you really study the boards, because it has four quadrants, and each quadrant can be flipped. So you get a certain number of new things, but every quadrant is always going to be the same,
所以你可以感觉到。它的工作方式是你基本上有一个网格，带有这些小机器人视觉上可以反弹的角度，嗯，好的，不是像，因此得名反弹，是的，所以它就像，你知道，如果它撞到一个角度，你知道它会走，或者如果它撞到一堵墙，它会反弹回来，它像那些激光迷宫之一吗？完全正确，是的，游戏场地，好的，是的，它只是，所以你可以，它像，是的，用激光和窗户是一个很好的解释方式。你会有一个带有大量这些镜子的板子，有效地，这些机器人可以从上面反弹。你会翻一张卡片，显示像一个红色的圆圈，这意味着你需要让红色机器人到达红色圆圈，或者类似的东西。
so you can kind of get a sense. And the way it works is you basically have a grid with kind of angles that these little four robots visually can bounce off of kind of um okay not like hence the ricochet yeah so it's just like you know if it hits an angle you know it goes or if it hits a wall it'll bounce back is it like one of those laser mazes exactly yeah the the play field okay yeah it's just so you can it like, yeah, with lasers and windows is a great way to explain it. And you'll have this board with a ton of these mirrors, effectively, that these robots can bounce off of. And you'll flip a card that'll show like a red circle, which means you need to get the red robot to the red circle or something like that.
所以你可以大概了解一下。它的运作方式基本上是一个网格，上面有一些角度，这些小机器人可以从这些角度反弹，嗯，就像弹球游戏一样。对，如果它撞到一个角度，它就会转向，或者如果它撞到墙，它就会弹回来。就像那种激光迷宫吗？没错，就是那个游戏场地。用激光和窗户来解释确实很贴切。你会有一个布满镜子的棋盘，机器人可以从这些镜子上反弹。你会翻开一张卡片，上面显示一个红色的圆圈，这意味着你需要把红色机器人移动到红色圆圈的位置，诸如此类。
And so then you just stare. You stare like the six of you or the eight of you at this thing, like just trying to do it visually with trying to figure out where the ricochets land. And then at some point, someone will say seven or 14. And that's the number of reflections that it takes that robot to get there. And then the timer gets flipped. And if anyone after that can come up with a lower number in the 30 seconds then they'll say like 10 and uh and the person with the lowest number then gets
然后你们就盯着看。你们六个人或八个人盯着这个东西，试图通过视觉去推算反弹会落在哪里。然后到了某个时刻，有人会说七次或十四次。这就是机器人到达目的地所需的反射次数。接着计时器翻转。如果之后有人能在30秒内想出一个更小的数字，比如10，那么那个报出最小数字的人就
to show it if it's correct they get that card and that's it and then the the robot's in a new place the next thing gets flipped very simple game incredibly fun because some people will be like 24 and you're like how did you you can't do 24. And then they will have done 24. Anyway, very fun game. Haven't played it in years since I was down at Silicon Valley. But the point being, Catan, replayability off the charts. Yeah. Like I said, I used to play it every day for like over a year.
可以展示它是否正确，如果正确他们就能得到那张卡片，就是这样。然后机器人会出现在一个新的位置，下一张牌被翻开，非常简单的游戏，但极其有趣，因为有些人会说24次，你会想你怎么可能做到24次。结果他们真的做到了24次。总之，非常有趣的游戏。自从我在硅谷以来已经好几年没玩过了。但重点是，卡坦岛的重玩价值极高。是的，就像我说的，我曾经连续一年多每天都玩它。
Over a working year, we played every last time. So replayability very high. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在工作的一年里，我们每次都玩。所以重玩价值非常高。请务必查看您的播客应用程序或ADSP the podcast dot com上的节目说明，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。我是反大括号。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。